hello it welcome to this five minute
game here against grandmaster summer
cold
Slavko chi Chuck I went to all the other
kinds and he's playing a somewhat
strange set of him well with Bishop g5
it looks a little bit odd huh
yeah okay good see what happens does he
really want to play long castles in this
position it would be unusual let's say
if I do this dude is he playing xe5
ready Wow okay hmm isn't this a good
position for me I mean what what's going
on here d6 song is that the problem okay
so I can play kick kick on c3 year this
is very probably a risky decision he's
got this d6 move of course I can always
go go f6 I mean let's see what happens I
don't don't quite I don't quite see the
point here what do I did so okay if I
take him he's going to take a play Queen
d4 which is a problem so this is not
possible
[Music]
if I can eat six in this position yeah I
know I shouldn't spend too much time and
then lose on time d6 I wanted to play b6
and break break a center I just wonder
if there is some technical idea if white
that I'm not seeing because if there is
known then I'm okay because I mean does
this this these pawns are not supported
maybe like a knight you know what that
doesn't work
94 I mean it works in the sense that it
is not terrible or solve it I don't see
a huge problem I can just take c5 and
fortunately that night on d3 is not
super stable that's a pretty pretty cool
move if I think did you cannot take
before that is what is doing checking me
on 94 maybe okay I will take this
94 or what is the deal I have to be if
he gets somehow pawn to c6 then yeah I
had something to be avoided
he gets that pawned duel in motion but
currently I don't see how that should
work 94 maybe attacking my Knights but
then I can take c5 pawn c5 and then I
don't really see a big issue here we've
all seen what he does but I think it
should it should be a night movie
otherwise I would just take c5 here
maybe 95 intending to go d6 yeah maybe
it could be an alternative he's taking a
very long time here trying to figure
this out
yeah okay for potentially d6 sorry d7
one Naija form that it's definitely also
also possible might take this it looks
it looks shaky my position looks a bit
shaky but a good age five I don't I
don't quite see how he's going to punish
me it's very much possible that there is
something would now G 4 I have h 5 twin
age 6 King back and there is nothing 94
named him
okay
there's something happening on to be
followed how Pecos Knight g4 there is
also Queen to h4 covering age six
okay so maybe there's a three
maybe there's a three the a it looks
lame but I came if I spent two minutes
now I'm losing on time
yeah I just try okay Queen to b6 is that
that's a problem it says something that
I'm missing Queen e7 maybe or so but I
know I'm not going back C 5 C 5 is also
hanging
Queen b6 is not really helping me
hmm how do I get rid of all this and I'm
warning the what come in to g5 trying to
actively defend okay just not just don't
want to play completely passive moves so
Knight d3 is that ridiculous sighs from
the ridiculous this one for Queen takes
age three
try to be active here
the move a3 is very irritating and
here's various sacrifices there I
thought this isn't so terrible
check-check
it's go check on three and he's seven I
got damnit check that is really really
unnecessary dose again checks usual
unnecessary check whatever what I said
it's on time really lost of course here
how did I caught injure into the time
disadvantage yeah anyway so again we can
yeah I mean okay it was a super
complicated position of course like look
here I really wasn't sure what's going
on and I'm not surprised that the engine
is giving white some advantage in the
initial stages like here yeah this is a
tricky move before somewhere I think
does this made sense and now f6 maybe
was good
it's not that's not extremely intuitive
f6 looks very ugly know that the waiver
enables then this move okay now I didn't
think of anything like that green g5
Queen f5 this actually what stockfish
also wants to play rook ft8 you know why
this is completely completely lost Queen
f3 check yeah I'm totally winning check
until I make f6 that's just ridiculous
Queen f6 and white resigns check yeah I
don't know I've got 9 seconds here yeah
a little bit rusty of course haven't
played much blitz but it's a bit of a
shame like it this is extremely easy and
f6 I mean 27 it's not exactly rocket
science
ok guys thanks for watching